now this section is called working
mathematically I'm not a huge fan of
that title because to be honest I feel
like that's the whole that's the whole
thing is it everything working Rafa
matically like what's the rest are just
sitting around mathematically anyway
what makes these problems different from
the rest oh I'm acting different okay
any suggestions apart from the fact that
they're harder I'm trying to work out
why they hardly why are working method
what qualities do work in mathematical
questions out that make what is good
yeah yeah okay so I guess they could say
they're more complicated or there's more
steps so instead of you just have to do
the one thing and then you're done your
move on to the next one okay often
you've got a this process you've got to
go through in the the problem isn't just
simply very quickly solved you've got to
substantive it to me sample maker yeah
all right yeah he is racing by now not
only that well you have a look at some
of these questions right they don't
provide you they don't provide all the
information right or the information
they provide you is sometimes it's
unclear how it's useful right so for
instance if you have a look at this
sheet even from where you're sitting
right you can see there's some diagrams
here yeah but not all the questions have
diagrams even if they do involve some
shape or geometry right so these
questions are the top infra yep the very
first what we're going to do doesn't
provide you a diagram but you really
need one it's almost impossible to solve
it effectively and make sure that you
have an accurate answer without having
done that okay okay now oh those i think
is sort of the creak of things let's do
the first one together now as usual with
working mathematical problems right
because is more complicated right what
the things that will help us is to look
and as you go through the question right
you try and express or articulate what's
there on your paper as you do then you
start to understand it better
it's a little bit like when you have any
conversation with someone I don't have
your experiences before but if you're
talking to someone and what they're
trying to explain she was difficult tip
for you well I went helpful is you try
it in during the course of the
conversation you see they talked for a
minute and you see now let me see if I
get this straight and you try and say it
back to them in the same word okay it's
actually a really good listening skill
it'll help you rather than all the
information like washing over you you'll
get an idea what's going on so let's
read and it start to put pen to paper a
point is chosen at random on an interval
of length 25 centimeters from a points
chosen at random on an interval of
length 25 centimeters now at that moment
before I go any further I'm gonna stop
and I'm going to put a drawing on here
right which will explain or just you
know represent why I just read so you've
got an interval how long did they say it
was 125 centimeters I bigger but yeah
these good idea to keep up with 25
centimeters from end to end okay and
then they think I think they said the
start a point is pit a random somewhere
on this interval now I'm not going to
put my point just yet i will put
something in the middle but i mean the
point of saying it's picked at random
means it could be anywhere it could be
anywhere now let's move on next sentence
it says find the probability okay again
stop as soon as you see the word
probability right if you immediately
know there's going to be some kind of
fraction involved now one of the pieces
that make up the probability fraction is
something on top we r / something look
does anyone remember what the two guitar
okay so the numerator what are we
expecting it to be and there was a
phrase here excuse me favorite outcomes
in other words what are the parts that
you want right one of the things that
might happen which you're interested in
that's going to be the numerator okay
what's the denominator well then hmm now
i'm going to write down the length but
what it represents in a probability
question hmm ah I don't know which is
worse sneezing a lot or almost easing
and then you buddy decide that Wow
federal outcomes right our favorable
events if you like all the denominator
it's all the total events we have a name
for this it's called sample space it
means everything that can possibly
happen okay now when I say everything
that can possibly happen the question
gives you some examples of what can
happen what kind yeah yes the time
favorable outcomes to sample space okay
so for instance a point like this is not
part of the sample space why not it's
not on the line our interval right
because they said a point is chosen at
random somewhere on here so this is not
an option and this is not an option to
miss all of the possible outcomes the
sample space are on that line okay is
that all right so far good now we keep
going we've said this is a probability
right that the point is more than six
centimeters from the middle of the
interval that the point is more than six
centimeters from the middle of the
interval okay again I'm gonna think
about how i can represent that here or
what I'm what I've drawn okay where's
the middle of the interval you sort of
can draw it in right I guess if you are
to be taught a half centimeters on one
side tow and a half of me up so I'll put
that there ok that's the middle all
right now then they say what's the
probability that it's within six
centimeters of that six centimeters from
the middle 600 from the middle okay now
which side is a very good question right
now for instance let's put a point like
say here now I know I haven't given you
a scale but safe for argument it's like
two centimeters from the middle ok does
that fit what they're asking is that a
favorable outcome let me read it again
let me read it again find the
probability that the point is more than
six centimeters from the middle you're
correct it's not favorable it's too
close I want to be further away don't I
ok so I want yeah it's right I already 6
plus ok so for instance where would six
be I mean I get maybe somebody like know
that ok roughly ok now let's talk about
both sides in second anywhere in this
spot you're busted I'm to closer to the
middle yes but I can make the same
argument going to the right as well as
the left right I can say you know I said
two centimeters to the left in the first
case what to say it's alright i'm still
in trouble i am not far enough away ok
so I'm going to go six centimeters to
the left and i'm also going to go six
centimeters to the right ok now those
areas there I don't want to be in there
I don't want to be in there I want to be
outside that further away ok so
therefore to mark that in I'm going to
put that in another color maybe you've
got like a red pen or something like
that ok this part over here ok that's
good that's far enough away that's
favorable ok and I've got the same thing
on the left hand side
okay so if I'm anywhere in that green
shaded area I'm good okay those are the
favorable outcomes now the question then
is how much of the lie in the interval
how much of it is green how much of it
is great hmm now I don't have any
measurements on here right but i do have
measurements eat here in the middle dodo
okay all is this area that I wanted to
avoid how long is it in total well it's
tosin is 616 the other so this this area
here 12 centimeters that's what I want
to avoid okay so when I say what are the
favorable outcomes it's going to be the
whole leg take away that bad spot the
spot I want to avoid take away 12 done
right you see what I've done that's how
I've worked out what the favorable
outcomes either the outside their the
leftovers if you like now what's the
total sample space where we said
anywhere on the line it's the lake is 25
okay now if your lights I suppose you
could have said centimeters here in
centimeters here but because it's a
fraction the centimeters the units were
just canceled okay probability doesn't
have your units attached to it even
though this question it does so 25-12 of
course that's equal to 13 and can we
simplify this fraction anymore is there
anything we can cancel there isn't it is
there and that's probably because 13
that's what I call if you remember a
prime number so it doesn't have any
factors with anything really just 1 and
13 okay so how do we approach this
question but first probably the most
important thing that I did was I drew a
diagram right uh all of the argument
that we've made and hopefully all logic
that makes sense to you depends on there
being a diagram I could try and do it in
my head that's just a little harder to
see yeah that's right so you see they
don't give you a diagram they're
expecting you to be able to interpret
the information that's there make your
own one
yeah that does take time is more time
consuming okay but but you know this
process of putting together diagram that
you've never seen before okay even
though you're not used to it it's a
skill that can be practiced just like
any other okay you mean draw a diagram
yeah that's right and particularly you
will see diagram lists questions under
working mathematically even though they
do need a diagram okay so whenever you
hear or read okay there's some
measurements or there's a shaping ball
the first thing you should do is start
drawing okay